hey everybody all right I'm in the midst
of a crazy day here but I felt I had to
do a quick video to address this viral
video that involved yours truly
a couple days ago I was up in Hamilton
Ontario in Canada I was doing an event
with Maxine Bernier who's running for
prime minister from the People's Party
of Canada which is a new party that he
formed and it's mostly a libertarian
party with some some conservative
beliefs but they're very big on free
speech I happened to be into that myself
and in any event Maxine and I were
headed to the event with a couple other
people and we had been warned already
that auntie fo was going to show up you
may remember that a few days before the
event that the school Mohawk College
that's the school that was hosting the
event they said that we were gonna have
to pay a ten times security fee than
they had originally said was gonna have
to be paid I offered to pay that myself
I would prefer not to do it but I wanted
to make sure that the event would go on
it's unclear even now days later if I am
allowed to even pay it because there may
be some campaign election law and
obviously the the People's Party of
Canada will do their due diligence and
if I can pay it then I'm happy to do it
because I offered it but if not then
they'll take care of it in any event we
got to the event security there said to
us you know there's a whole bunch of
anti-shah people here and if you don't
know anti 5 these are the cobra soldier
from GI Joe look-alikes who wear masks
and they block traffic and they often
get violent as they did with my friend
and former guests and you know up in
Portland
they stopped traffic they yelled people
you know everyone's a Nazi and a racist
and a bigot and all that they actually
although they called themselves an tyfa
as if they're anti-fascist they're the
ones using fascist tactics of violence
to silence people that they don't like
because irony in 2019 is apparently dead
our security people said you know if you
guys want to go in the back to make sure
that there's no incident feel free but
we all said no we've got to go in the
front we're not gonna be cowed and and
fearful of this group of goons and thugs
so we did go through and immediately
when I got out of the van you know
people scream and Nazi right in my face
and you know getting up in our face and
pushing and the whole thing and a couple
people were arrested anyway we end up
doing in the event which was just
wonderful it was about an hour and a
half long we had
great chat about freedom about Liberty
about free speech all of these things
there was nothing remotely racist
bigoted homophobic Islamophobic or any
of those other things but the video that
went viral is what I'm about to show you
now this is an 81 year old woman who was
on her way to the event take a look all
right so that video has been seen about
8 million times on Twitter alone and the
woman herself then did a follow up video
which is just beautiful I've dubbed her
Canada's grandma by the way here is
Canada's grandma free speech is the
cornerstone of our democracy and can
never and will never be denied yeah
that's right in Western societies you've
got to protect free speech for all
whether they be on the left or on the
right you know one of the other
interesting things of course about this
is the way that the media talks or often
doesn't talk about certain things
because one of the types of fake news
out there is that when the media just
ignores something when they purposely
don't talk about something that goes
against their narrative I would argue
that's a type of fake news so in this
case try to imagine the reverse of this
so what happened here was that a
right-leaning speaker who is not racist
in any way or any of those things was
going to be stopped from speaking and
then to turned violent via left-wing
anti-shah people far-left ante 5 people
but now reverse it imagine if it had
been Justin Trudeau darling of the left
and there had been right-wing or even
though it's Canada dare I say Trump
supporters outside violently blocking
people and screaming all of these
horrible things do you think the media
would have covered that but the media
barely covered this except good good
citizens did the CBC which is Canada's
broadcaster state broadcaster they
finally choked out an article but they
didn't even address anything that we
talked about inside because to their
dismay there was nothing bigoted or
racist or homophobic or the rest of it
in any event I am going to keep doing
these talks I will keep talking to
people
I find interesting and thoughtful and
and we've got to call out the bad guys
when we see them an tyfa are the bad
guys all they you want to protest you
you bring signs and you let people
peacefully enter you let people
peacefully walk out you can hand out
flyers if you want you know there was a
night during the jordan peterson tour i
think it was in amsterdam where there
was a whole bunch of protesters and they
stood outside very peaceful they handed
out leaflets about what their criticism
of jordan was I actually read one of the
leaflets on stage to a couple thousand
people because they were very misguided
in what they thought he believes but I
thought these are the type of protesters
that actually respect Western values an
tyfa is not that group of people so just
be clear on who the good guys are and
who the bad guys are and those who are
fighting for free speech and those who
are trying to silence it anyway thanks a
lot everybody have a great weekend if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlists
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell